Matadi town in Congo.
The Nzanza neighbourhood is a slum.
Hundreds of teenage gangs operate here.
They’re called the KULUNA.
The gangs are spreading out to the big cities like a virus.
It’s a social epidemic. Kulunas are mainly
involved in theft and robbery.
Supposedly employment opportunities
are increasing in the country,
but the reality is massive unemployment.
The resource extraction sector is currently booming but it’s controlled by government officials.
According to those who live in Nzanza,
they only give jobs to their own people.
And the rest have to survive however they can.
Becoming a Kuluna is one of the popular options.
This is Shina Ram.
The leader of the Outlaws gang.
Shina Ram is the short form of Shina Rambo,
a character from a Nigerian action movie.
What's the name of your town?
It's Matadi
And your gang's name?
Sans Loi, the Outlaws. This is the Devil's base
The Outlaws are a young gang.
The kids’ are 15-17 years old.
They share a street in the Nzanza neighbourhood
with the Tricage gang.
Together they form the Devil group.
Are you afraid of anything?
I only fear prison
What do you think about your life?
It stinks!
The Outlaws control the public restroom, while Tricage lords it over the Paris restaurant.
This is the Devil’s turf
and the police station is on the same street.
It’s 300 metres from the Paris to the precinct.
Line up! Attention
That could've been better!
Major Charles is the Chief at the police station
and it’s his job to deal with the Devil group
and the other street gangs.
Many bad things happen here these days
It’s fashionable among
the youth to become kulunas
However, they're bandits
They walk the streets with machetes and
rob people, in broad daylight and at night
They steal, mug, and
injure people with their machetes
Today, here in Nzanza,
we've got a lot on our hands
Matadi was founded in a rocky place.
That’s what ‘matadi’ actually means, ‘a rock’.
And since its founding, the main jobs here
are quarrying and stonecutting.
But this kind of work is not to everyone’s liking.
As a rule, the devils don’t do anything during the day. They just hang about.
The guys smoke marijuana non-stop.
It's the cheapest drug here.
In Congo, as in many countries, drug use is illegal.
But it doesn’t stop the gang members and
they seem unconcerned about
the harm it does their health.
By nightfall, many of them would be literally speechless.
-What is your name?
-Manzak
What does it mean?
It means 'claw'
So I'm a good pickpocket
I'm Rais
They call me Rais because I'm a cool devil!
I'm Lord Devil in this gang
Lord Devil! What do you mean?
I mean, I'm devilishly good at getting scalps!
Nzanza streets are like a maze.
If you go there, you won’t be able to get out on your own.
Even if they’re just messing around,
it still has violent overtones.
That’s how life is here.
The public restroom is a source of regular income for the Outlaws gang.
There are plenty of houses here that have no plumbing, so the restroom is in high demand.
‘To go number two’ will cost you 100 francs,
while taking a shower is also 100 francs.
Our toilet's very clean
It's so clean that if you buy me a banana,
I can eat in the toilet
This guy keeps it clean
The entrance fee is 100 francs,
although if you have no money,
we can let you in free
Hey, man, is it clean there?
Come on
This is a friend of Shina Ram’s.
He calls himself King Kalamba.
He’s a good football player,
but he can’t afford to keep on training.
Now we're in the men's toilets
We conduct our business here
The Outlaws run a protection racket at the restroom
and every day they get money from the manager.
He’s been in cahoots with the gang for a long time,
but he appears to resist them in order to
keep up appearances.
While they were extorting money from the manager,
one of the gang members got sick.
This is our friend
We received a call
saying he'd been arrested
He's not feeling well
We don't know what happened to him
I know this guy
He plays for Damar FC
They're really bad boys
Their friend was arrested recently
He's currently in jail
Oh dear me!
That one's a very dangerous individual
If you meet him at night, that's it!
We're looking for him now
What was the last thing you stole?
I stole this phone
When was the first time you had sex?
My first time? I was nine
Nine!
Who do you hate the most?
There's one man. He's a cop
Why do you hate him so much?
He snoops on us all the time
What will happen if you two meet?
A big scrap!
Look at this!
If you hit me with it, it won't hurt me
But if we meet one-on-one and start fighting...
I'll smash your head in
So there! No hard feelings
But I'm just poor
and I really need money. I don't have any!
The Paris restaurant hasn’t been a restaurant
for quite some time now.
It’s been a long time since the denizens of Nzanza
have had enough money to dine out.
That’s where the Tricage gang,
mentors of the Outlaws, hang out.
Tricage’s main goal is to save up
enough money to buy a boat
and go to sea via the Congo River.
And after that, on to Europe or even America.
Fiston, the gang leader, speaks
about the code of the ‘hood'.
We steal and rob somewhere else
It's a bad idea to do it in your neighbourhood
You must go someplace else
because our mothers and sisters trade here
We need to maintain order here
Of course, the younger ones don’t listen to the elders.
And now Shina Ram is plotting something at the neighbourhood’s southern outskirts.
Do you think it's more difficult
to kill or give birth?
I think killing is more
difficult than giving birth
So, if you have to kill someone...
you'll stop to think?
No, I won't think.
If I have to kill you, I will
Who would you like to be?
President Kabila
President Kabila doesn't seem
to be able to give everyone a good life
When I'm in his place, I'll do it differently
Everyone will have a good life
Even if Shina Ram ever runs for president, it’s going to be very hard for him to win.
The ordinary people don’t like the Kulunas.
When Kabila was in power,
the rules were stricter
If you got caught with a marijuana joint,
your fingers would get cut off right away
If you got caught stealing,
your hand was chopped off
Now it's anarchy!
They must catch those kulunas and chop
off their hands, straight away!
So when one goes down the street
people could see he's a thief
because his hands would look
like cut-off shorts
To be taken to the station is not the worst thing that could happen to a Kuluna.
Lynch-mob mentality is typical in the Congo.
They put a tire round a criminal, douse him in petrol,
and set him on fire.
This man was burnt
That's where his legs used to be
And here's his mouth
Nzanza consists of thousands of little houses that nestle cheek by jowl on a hill,
which overlooks the city jail.
What you see over there is Matadi's main prison
That's it there
King Kalamba is packing up a food parcel for one of the gang members who’s currently doing time.
These are beans, here's fish, this is manioc
You don't get these in prison
If you're given anything,
it's some kind of rubbish
That's why you have to bring them food
Food must be passed to prisoners not via the main entrance,
but through a hole in the fence.
That's it...
You stay here, and I'll go inside
The prison security doesn't allow filming,
so you stay, and I'll go to Marshal
The police consider Kalamba a good kid. He’s a footballer and can walk around freely.
But Shina Ram has to hide out in the
Paris’s shower room.
He’s a wanted criminal, and tries to avoid
being seen on the main street.
There’s a police officer on the beat there right now.
The police are nearby,
so why can't they catch you?
Because we're very smart,
and they're dumb
But they're so close!
Yes, but they can't catch us,
because we're very careful
- How do you avoid being caught?
- When they show up, we promptly run away
That's why they can't do anything
What do you tell a girl who likes you?
- Simply 'I love you'
- And then what?
Well, then we'll talk about love...
What could make you hit a woman?
If I saw her with another man, I'd beat her up
and kill him
It seems something is going on.
All the Devils are assembling in the Paris.
You embarrass me
Oh come on, why?
I feel awkward
Don't say that
I'm still a child
Come on!
You're an old lady, not a child!
Kiss me!
I'm too young
No one's innocent at your age
Are you drunk? You look wasted
No, come on!
Is it okay to fall in love at this age?
Of course, when else?
Fiston is unhappy with a recent robbery
committed by Shina Ram,
so the older devils will fight the younger ones.
Fighting in the ‘hood could be dangerous.
So, they’ve agreed to go
to the other side of the Congo river.
But one car can’t take all those who want to fight.
Muri! Where's your list?
We have to take people by the list!
Why are you all so stupid?
In the end, both gangs travel in the same car,
to save on gas.
Usually, there’s a huge traffic jam before
the bridge over the Congo river.
The bridge was a gift to Matadi from Japan.
And so here we are.
The very next day, the Devils go swimming together in the Congo river.
This is our river.
It's where the devils bathe
I'm the master,
and my apprentice is over there
It’s not just a group logo, it’s a magic charm.
Other gangs might ask a sorcerer for help to take over the Devils’ turf or to kill someone.
This sign breaks any spell.
This is our Devil base's sign
If you come, you'll see it,
be it in the light of day
or in the dark of night
A machete is 32 inches long.
The outlaws say it’s the optimal length for a machete.
Pardon me, ma'am,
do you have a cat?
No, I don't have a cat
Do you know anyone here who does?
OK, she says there's one over there
The Devils are going from door to door
trying to buy a cat.
In Nzanza, it’s not that easy.
To the boys, a cat is a magical animal that gives people strength and ferocity.
But it requires eating a feline.
So the Kulunas eat cats 2 or 3 times a week.
Besides, a cat is the cheapest meat you can get.
The Devils are throwing a big party tonight.
Friends and neighbours gather for the dinner
made of cat meat.
When we eat cats,
an evil spirit enters us
It makes us good warriors
We won't be scared during a brawl,
we'll fight like real beasts
The main street is the only one in the neighbourhood.
All the action happens in the small alleys
between the houses.
As soon as the crowd gathers for the party,
a makeshift barbershop starts up.
I'm the best
That's the magic of beauty
The white building up there is a church.
- Do you believe in God?
- Yes
I'm a Christian
- Why have you stopped going to church?
- Because they lie to you there
Girls come to services wearing short skirts
The pastor gets a crush on them
and they have sex
If you go up the path, you’ll end up at the restroom.
If you go down, you’ll reach the prison.
This is a very bad place to raise kids
It's just awful
Even when our older brothers
were growing up here,
they ended up becoming bad guys
The kids that are born here today
will also grow up to be bad people,
just like their fathers
because this place is absolutely cursed
What's your favourite kind of car?
I like limos
- So, if you had the money, you'd buy one?
- Straight away
You'd drive around Matadi in a limo?
No, in a different place
Like where?
In the country where you live
- What will your house look like?
- My house?
It'll have everything:
carpeting, air conditioning, and a plasma TV
The lads haven’t partaken of cat yet,
but they’re already angry.
They can’t agree on how to share it fairly.
- Let's start drinking already
- Wait, we can't start just like that!
They're going to smoke and drink what's theirs
and we'll have what's ours!
This is ours, this is ours!
We're senior here
We've counted it all
This is ours
That's the way it is...
Harmony!
When I'm here, all is good
This is me – Shakira
Everything's gonna be great!
No, they've never hurt me
If they did,
I'd never come back
But I am here,
so that means something
A week after filming, Shina Ram and Rais
attacked an appliance store.
A guard called the police, and when they arrived on the scene, they opened fire.
A bystander was killed by a stray bullet.
Shina Ram and Rais are currently being held in the Matadi city prison.
What was the best moment of your life
that you can remember?
I haven't had one yet...
I will when I have money
Which parent do you love more?
Your mum or dad?
Mum
Why mum?
Cause when I'm in jail, she'll bail me out